[Music]
data centers use about one percent of
electricity in the world
so today let's explore how data centers
are powered especially in a world
confronting the threat of climate change
in september 2020 google ceo sundar
pichai unveiled that google would become
one of the first companies to operate
carbon free 24 hours a day 7 days a week
365 days a year by 2030.
carbon free means running data centers
on clean electricity that does not come
from fossil fuels
but how does a global technology company
with a constant need for electricity
achieve the ability to slash all of its
carbon emissions within a decade
well that's a big question and to answer
it we have to go back in time
in 2006 google installed over 9000 solar
panels in its mountain view california
buildings
and learned how to optimize our
efficiency with tricks like finding
optimal locations and washing them
but six years later it was still a
unique and custom process to buy
renewable energy traditional power
companies didn't have the experience
with the volume of wind and solar that
google was seeking
but fast forward to today and google has
become the largest corporate purchaser
of clean energy and utility companies
now have an idea of what's needed making
it an industry standard
just like computer chips higher
production volumes create lower costs
as clean energy has gone mainstream the
cost has declined and wind and solar are
now cheaper than any other resource in
many areas of the world
adding clean energy to grids is only one
part of the strategy
data centers also need to be designed
efficiently
historically it took a massive amount of
cooling a data center technician in the
1980s would be wearing a very thick
sweater since temperatures inside were
around 58 degrees all the time
today a t-shirt suffices
a lot of effort has been placed on
designing better cooling systems and
isolating the hot aisles from the cold
aisles
in fact in 2018 a data center engineer
created an ml algorithm that
exponentially improved cooling loads by
at least 30 percent
this ai powered efficiency
recommendation system ingested all the
cooling system data we had on power
temperature and pump speeds and fed it
to neural networks that learned how to
operate the mechanical systems more
efficiently
teams of engineers also worked on how to
make the servers more efficient to
squeeze more computation out of each
machine
in the past an idle server could use
just as much energy as one that is
processing at max capacity
one way to improve this capacity was to
virtualize machines
that means you take a physical device
such as a server and run multiple
instances of an operating system
it's almost like having 10 20 or even 50
different computing loads running on one
physical device keeping utilization high
and energy emissions low
between 2010 and 2018 overall computing
efficiency grew by
550 percent in data centers
and in 2019 google reported that its
data centers delivered over seven times
as much computing power with the same
amount of electrical energy
google began to buy enough solar and
wind energy to match its total
electricity use worldwide since 2017
but there was still more work to do for
example there were still data centers
that could only use solar energy during
the day but at night we're using carbon
intensive energy from the grid
so the energy teams at google started
thinking about our mission in a
completely different way how could we
match every bit byte search payment and
translation to a zero carbon electron
googler anna radovanovic understood that
there was a way to use data to tell when
power was clean or dirty at any given
time
since google logs data on every single
compute workload we could analyze which
tasks did not need to happen immediately
such as the training of machine learning
models
these tasks could be safely scheduled at
a later time and powered with clean
energy without affecting performance
this is called demand response which is
not a new concept for big energy
consumers like grocery stores offices or
factories who reduce their energy demand
at certain times of the day
even though this concept has been around
a long time google is going about it in
a pretty unique way and carbon aware
computing has made a huge shift in the
industry
although complicated it's key to
decarbonizing the digital economy
by mid-2020 all the elements came
together
incredibly cheap renewable energy
radical improvements in efficiency
higher density batteries green hydrogen
and novel types of greener nuclear
plants
for the first time google was able to
put a firm date on our 24 7 carbon goal
this is so important to us as the next
decade is vital to limit climate change
and make a huge shift in our
relationship with natural resources
if you want to learn more check out the
links below and stay tuned for more on
discovering data centers